♪ ♪
>> Tucker: AS MANY TIMES AS WE
SAY IT OUT LOUD, IT'S PRETTY
UNBELIEVABLE THAT ERIC SWALWELL,
A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE HAD SEX WITH A CHINESE
SPY CALLED FANG FANG.
IT'S REMARKABLE PATRICK DONAHOE
IS A MAJOR GENERAL IN THE
U.S. ARMY.
HE'S A GENERAL BUT HE DOESN'T
SEEM AS INTERESTED IN KEEPING
THE COUNTRY SAFE AS HE DOES IN
PROMOTING A VERY SPECIFIC
POLITICAL POINT OF VIEW, HE
SPENDS MOST OF HIS TIME
APPARENTLY ONLINE HARASSING
POLITICAL OPPONENTS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
LAST WEEK, HE WAS LECTURING A
STUDENT AT HILLSDALE COLLEGE ON
THE MERITS OF MANDATORY
VACCINES.
COME GET YOUR BOY HE BUILT, THAT
GUY IS REALLY A GENERAL?
THAT'S ONE ANOTHER USER ASKED
HOW MANY WARS HAVE YOU WON?
RATHER THAN ASK THAT QUESTION
HONESTLY, THE ANSWER IS ZERO, HE
RESPONDED THIS WAY -- "DON'T BE
A SHILL FOR PUTIN."
HERE YOU HAVE A MAJOR GENERAL IN
THE U.S. ARMY ACCUSING
APPARENTLY AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
OF BEING A SHILL FOR PUTIN
BECAUSE THAT PERSON CRITICIZED
JOE BIDEN.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THAT?
I HIGHLY POLITICIZED U.S.
MILITARY, A MILITARY THAT ACTS
AS THE ARMED ENFORCERS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION?
YOU SHOULDN'T BE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT SPIRIT AND NED ORION'S
FOUNDER AND CEO OF AMERICAN
MAJORITY.
I CAN'T HELP THINKING -- YOU
THINK OF ALL THE GUYS WHO JOINED
THE U.S. MILITARY BECAUSE THEY
LOVE AMERICA AND THEY WANT TO
DEFEND THE COUNTRY AND WERE
ENDLESSLY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
REAL SACRIFICE, IT'S A CLICHE
BUT IT'S TRUE, THEY DO SACRIFICE
IN A BIG WAY.
AND THEY HAVE LEADERS LIKE THIS
WHO SPEND THEIR DAYS ON TWITTER:
PEOPLE PRUDENT PUTINS BECAUSE
THEY DISAGREE WITH JOE BIDEN,
WHY IS THIS GUY STILL COMMANDING
ANYONE, WHY HAS HE NOT RESIGNED?
>> I THINK THE LEFT HAS YET
AGAIN BEEN SUCCESSFUL AGAINST
ANOTHER LONG MARCH TO THE CEDAR
LEADERSHIP WERE MILITARY, I
DON'T THINK IT SHOULD BE THAT
SURPRISING, ONE OF THE SENIOR
OFFICERS HAVE GOTTEN ADVANCED
DEGREES FROM INDOCTRINATION
CENTERS OF HIGHER LEARNING LIKE
HARVARD OR COLUMBIA AND A LOT OF
THEM GOT THEIR START I THINK IF
WE WERE TO LOOK BACK IN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHERE THEY
GOT ADVANCEMENT, NOT NECESSARILY
THROUGH MERIT, HOW GOOD ARE YOU
AT TACTICS AND HOW GOOD ARE YOU
AT KILLING AND DESTROYING, HOW
GOOD ARE YOU AT PARROTING THE
LEFT'S TALKING POINTS?
EVEN MORE SO IT APPEARS THIS
GENERAL DONAHOE THINKS HE WILL
WIN PRAISE AND ADVANCEMENT BY
ATTACKING CONSERVATIVE POPULACE.
WE HAVE GOTTEN TO THIS POINT
WERE A MAJOR GENERAL IN THE
MILITARY WHO LOOKS AT ATTACKING
A PRIVATE CITIZEN'S RIGHT TO
SPEECH WHICH INCLUDES A RIGHT TO
DISSENT IS THAT WITH THE RIGHT
THING TO DO INSTEAD OF EXTENDING
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE FREEDOM OF
DISSENT.
I THINK CONSERVATIVES NEED TO
HAVE ADJUSTMENT IN THEIR
THINKING AND A START TO LOOK AT
THE WORLD IN A DIFFERENT FILTER
IN WHICH THE DOJ AND THE FBI AND
QUITE FRANKLY THE MILITARY WHICH
ARE SUPPOSED TO DEFEND THE RULE
OF LAW AND PROTECT AMERICANS
BASIC RIGHTS ARE NO LONGER DOING
THAT FOR BASICALLY ACTING AS A
PRAETORIAN GUARD FOR THE RULING
CLASS, THE MINISTRY OF STATE
WHICH IS A VERY DANGEROUS PLACE
NOT ONLY DOMESTICALLY BUT ALSO
ON THE INTERNATIONAL LEVEL AS
WELL.
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY REPUBLICANS IN THE CONGRESS,
WHY MITCH McCONNELL OR
ADAM KINZINGER OR LIZ CHENEY,
WHY DON'T THEY SIGN OFF OF THE
MILITARY BUDGET?
I WANT TO DEFEND THE COUNTRY BUT
PATRICK DONAHOE HAS TO LEAVE
FORT BENNING AND RESIGN, WHY
DOESN'T SOMEBODY SAY THAT?
>> REPUBLICANS HAVE LOST SIGHT
OF THE FACT THEY DO HAVE
OVERSIGHT, THEY HAVE LOST THE
GUTS AND LOST THE COURAGE TO DO
SO IN WHICH CHRIS WRAY AND
DONAHOES, THEY HAVE POLITICIZED
MILITARY AND THE FBI, THEY
CONTINUE TO DO THESE THINGS
BECAUSE I THINK THEY CAN GET
AWAY WITH IT AND IT'S SIMPLY A
LACK OF POLITICAL COURAGE BY
REPUBLICANS IN D.C. WHO WOULD
RATHER POSTURE AND ASCENDANT
SHARPLY WORDED LETTERS INSTEAD
OF ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING BY
CUTTING BUDGETS AND HAVING REAL
CONSEQUENCES.
>> Tucker: I FEEL SO SORRY FOR
PEOPLE WHO SERVE UNDER HIM, HE